[Music]
you can see them on Jupiter's moon Io
you can find some on Neptune's icy moon
Triton volcanoes erupting so explosively
that they've reach out into space
imagine if our own moon could pull that
off or even worse what if a giant
volcano on earth could spew out lava
that high what would it do to our
climate and is there any way we could
outlive such a volcanic show this is
what if and here's what would happen if
a volcano erupted into space I can tell
you this right away if the volcano
erupts with enough power to shoot debris
from the Earth's surface into space we'd
all be dead most likely earth might seem
like a volcanic world but compared to
some places in the solar system we ain't
seen nothing yet
Mars wasn't always the cold red planet
we see today it used to have water and
an earth-like atmosphere it could even
have hosted some simple life forms it
also had the largest active volcano in
the solar system Olympus Mons this giant
mountain is 3 times the height of the
biggest mountain we have here on earth
it hasn't been active for millions of
years but when it was it could have shot
lava beyond the Martian atmosphere well
we can't know for sure if it did
shooting lava into space is a drink that
not every planet has but further in the
solar system sits the most distant
planet from the Sun Neptune and it has a
moon that's capable of spitting blues
about 8 kilometers into space Triton
this spectacular event was discovered by
Voyager 2 the only space probe that's
ever visited the distant ice giants moon
only Triton isn't erupting with lava
it's spewing out nitrogen ice
and that brings us to another moon in
the solar system
io is one of Jupiter's moons it's
covered with active volcanoes
unlike the volcanoes on earth io erupts
plumes of sulphur one of its biggest
volcanoes the active lava lake
Loki Patera sends such powerful
eruptions that we can detect the
infrared light from them using
telescopes on earth pretty cool right
now why doesn't our moon have similar
volcanic shows billions of years ago the
moon was blowing up with violent
volcanoes 100 million years ago the moon
was still erupting volcanic burps if the
dinosaurs had invented telescopes they
would have seen some lava spewed from
the moon's surface although our moon
doesn't have any active volcanoes today
there's still a lot of magma under its
surface and it could erupt in the future
if humans or whatever else is dominant
on earth at that time are interested in
astronomy then they could observe with
the dinosaurs missed the only thing
earth would get from volcanic eruptions
on the moon would be a spectacular view
but it would be a different story if the
earth itself erupted into space
there are two things that affect how
volcanoes erupt the first is gravity on
Mars the gravity is lower than it is on
earth that's why it would take longer
for magma on the red planet to rise to
the surface on some volcanic world's
gravity is what's causing eruptions in
the first place eyal for example has an
elliptical orbit that means that
sometimes it gets closer to Jupiter and
the other times it distances itself from
the gas giant
Jupiter's enormous gravitational pull
constantly deforms Iowa and that in turn
is heating the moon from the inside this
is what's called tidal heating the
second factor is atmosphere it affects
how high volcanoes can eject their
plumes earth has a thick turbulent
atmosphere and that's why it can only
spew volcanic debris up to 60 kilometers
high not enough to reach outer space
which generally starts at 100 kilometers
above the Earth's surface for earth to
produce an eruption that would spread
into space it would need to be one
incredibly huge volcano
somewhere between 18 and 40 million
years ago the most violent volcanic
event happened on earth Nagari de
caldera a volcano located in today's
Colorado United States ejected 5,000
cubic kilometers of volcanic material
and killed everything in the radius of
at least 160 kilometers around it and it
did most likely shoot debris into space
we just weren't around to see that
volcanic particles can theoretically
reach space they just have to move fast
enough developing the minimum speed of
eleven point two kilometers per second
they also need enough energy to
withstand Earth's turbulent atmosphere
which will be slowing them down and
heating them up at the same time
lastly the particles have to be big
enough not to evaporate as I said it
would have to be a huge eruption many
people would die instantly they would
either be hit by the large chunks of
rock or suffocated by the massive gas
clouds even if you managed to survive
that your days would be numbered because
all the energy from such an event would
result in global climate change and
could end up causing a mass extinction
our planet could erase humanity from its
surface forever just like it erased
dinosaurs some six
six million years ago and while we will
probably never experience volcanoes
erupting into space we could get hit by
a huge asteroid one day but that's a
story for another what if
[Music]